ooto TV presents the all-time best
comebacks in Tekken 7
tournaments want the na we're going to
find out in just a bit now let's see
what's going to happen here spend that
rage immediately M Corner pressure
coming from whatab F needs to get out of
this situation but kid there's going to
be so much damage on the board for wab
infested needs to guess right here or
else it's going to be the death of him
Wabi has so much help he's confident
he's he's just backing away goes for the
low again the counter hit infested has
rage gets the counter hit guaranteed
infested Falls up with the combo has
rage still he chooses to use it just to
go back to the wall let's see what's
going to happen here infested looking so
strong right now if he gets this wrong
it's going to be the death he gets it
infesta takes it ladies and gentlemen
what a is eliminated infested making
sure his shot counted just when he was
down and out just a standing jab five
rounds in a row for jdcr here the crowd
wakes up they're like come on Jimmy they
know he needs his oh no shut up
everybody what a b what a bad start for
this round jdcr five rounds straight
right
now pressure oh man he smells it he
smells it and it smells like
[__] wait a second It's Not Over it
smells good God it smells good the best
smelling [__] ever it smells good
yeah okay all
right oh counter hit that's going to
hurt and he makes the adjustment here
beautiful combo and looking much like
the last round right now KN waiting to
explode maybe be able to take it oh what
a side step
beautiful and that's very very going to
be big damage but not quite enough to
tie it up okay side stepping right
getting away from the wall what a block
too far away and again just poking away
using the lows at different variances
here he has to watch out for the rage
Drive the BL stuff is coming any moment
now oh
man there it is he blew
it the time oh the mixup what's he going
to do there's no time left unbelievable
the time look at the time oh you got a
follow up unbelievable the lead oh he
got the lead
oh Aran Ash defeating KNE again GE has
good Wings GE has good wings and Khan
looking to spread his wings into the
Winner's final if he can get one more
round super Kuma needs to make three
rounds straight for this comeback here
see what happens here superum of course
getting close to half of his bar build
will he be able to explode he does KH we
for counters have been terrible he's
made like five or six attempts none of
them have worked out oh he Tech rolls
but it l y here we go opportunity
R oh my God that wall messed him up he
could have gone for a rage I'm sorry he
could have gone for something just to
get some extra damage but he was not
able to do it he's he is dead ra mod
bended this should be it R himan for the
victory oh my gosh and that's going to
do it KH takes it and he is moving four
lows for do it is the no G for the
set John do my God doin with these
decisions what is happening John Down
happen what is one more set up Sir one
more set
up John one one hit
away what is
happening my heart oh no oh W oh my God
John D finishing the one two went for
the two went for the two hit five rounds
straight for
straight I can't believe we might see an
American in winers finals my
God we're on the cusp and Majin he's
working that momentum for tracking moves
I can only make noises at this point I'm
sorry oh my gosh is he going to get the
mixup afterwards yes he does what's
going to happen here jdcr is going to
have to make a
move and he's using movement here jdcr
known for this oh he's going to go down
low is it going to be enough he might
kill he might
be oh he drops drops it he drops it oh
and Majin he is on a tear right now on
the verge of sending jdcr to losers oh
my God he's going to be my gosh he's
going to have to be careful though he's
in Rage he's going to beat him he has to
oh you got to be careful and that's
something that you rarely get hit by but
jdcr ready for look at the time look at
the time he's going to have to either
stay on the ground look at the time look
at him oh my god jdcr with an amazing
comeback God old versus CH in the twt
run back well underway oh my God went
for the high extension risky stuff but
chickin respecting it oh then do
extension off of him actually makes you
say get some of those followups now but
here we go chicken uh uh uh big damage
working on a perfect so far the to try
to close outside step two not going to
work oh sliding we back in this bad boy
oh boy we doing this
again oh we do I bet you won't do it
again oh my God oh my God look at it
look yo I was
good he has to be careful cuz that was I
was I was thinking flash right there too
yeah oh here we go good opportunity W he
he's trying to test him yeah oh he
caught him yeah switch on one just count
it this
goodu again
careful the wall I feel like he knew it
was coming everyone knew but what have
you got for us ey position what have you
got for us oh he's going he's going to
flip again God those sword St is it that
is I Fus this [__] pixel in the dream I
know you guys want to see a game three I
know you guys want to see it but MEK
doesn't mihawk doesn't big counter hit
going to get the wall so much damage
that's ok as well no not that bad that
is on the punish oh no break not that
yet one
more what's he going to do down for one
down for one is he going to be two
respectful hit the rip can he made the
comeback one hit
away oh my God no he's staying
alive no my oh my God oh my God don't do
this don't do this R don't do this rip
no no no way with a comeb by on set
point nor had to scoot up a little bit
get dck the high perfect dck from going
to carry to the wall it's going to do
tons damage back 32 shoulder big damage
50% lead 60
already wow what a block there from
Majin punish o he did muscle bu that's
so sick oh what he's doing
oh don't on the
ground is
exploding
woic for the top eight winner give her
the standing there destroying the the
pressure counter BR time no he's going
to get the wall damage here standing to
Savage Sword so much damage on but super
Kum needs one hit here he needs one hit
if he gets one hit here it's going to oh
my God if he gets one hit here it's
party time oh it's party time and CH is
invited oh here it is go why did you say
that Mark I want to see part oh my God
look at the he the demon and the demon
let's go I can't believe what we're
seeing it look at the life
oh my goodness is he he probably has a
sliver right he might have
a oh my God oh my let's
go than the
comeback good block man AR's defense is
still holding
up good confirm that's so cheap the Jabs
they're adding up once again huge lead
huge
lead
block good block again and rainbow Aron
about to take the tournament cany find
the way back into this holy
crap Aron for the win right now oh my
God got it
final right now it's like every time he
goes for it I mean I feel like Saint's
going to have to kind of like seal that
move away at this point in time have you
ever seen a jack player stop because
that's a move you want to use yeah hell
yeah abuse not against cudan look at
this flash kick
pressure okay oh that could be the move
that changes it as well the down forward
too that direction the tracking on that
side it could be a big factor oh swe and
that is always a common factory here
with maim was he's going to need such a
miracle he's going to need such a
miracle oh my God he got him not much
more of a miracle left oh my god oh no
and I don't think he hit a button at all
oh he got him I can't believe it what I
mean he got so many Miracle comebacks
did we miss something make sure to leave
a comment
below thanks for watching be sure to
leave a like And subscribe also huge
shout out to our patreon supporters if
you want to further support this Channel
and making more content like these
please visit the link to our patreon
page below the descript
[Music]
destion